es ist eine riesige solche nach
herzinfarkt oder schlaganfall sterben
die meisten menschen an krebs in
deutschland rund 9,5 millionen menschen
weltweit sind im jahr 2018 an krebs
verstorben 18 millionen
krebserkrankungen kam im selben jahr neu
hinzu die tendenz ist steigend das große
problem der großteil der krebserkrankung
wird erst erkannt wenn es schon fast zu
spät ist doch us fachleute haben jetzt
einen neuen bluttest entwickelt der
gleich 50 krebsarten frühzeitig erkennen
soll können wir den krebs damit endlich
besiegen klicks um science-fiction gibt
es drei mal in der woche und zwar
montags mittwochs und freitags spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts los geht's hat sie willkommen
die medizin hat in den letzten
jahrzehnten unglaubliche fortschritte
gemacht in den industrieländern werden
immer mehr menschen immer älter doch
damit stößt die medizin immer öfter auf
eine schlimme und quälende krankheit
krebs denn wenn immer mehr menschen
immer älter werden dann haben sie mehr
geraucht getrunken sind zu dick geworden
und auch rein statistisch steigt damit
das risiko an krebs zu erkranken und
schon seit vielen jahren arbeiten
forschungsteams weltweit mit hochdruck
daran tumorerkrankungen in sehr frühem
stadium zu erkennen denn für
krebspatientinnen und patienten ist es
entscheidend dass ihre erkrankung so
früh wie möglich erkannt wird im besten
fall passiert das schon bevor der krebs
gestreut hat denn dann kann der tumor im
idealfall sogar noch chirurgische
entfernt werden eine belastende
chemotherapie mit all ihren
schwerwiegenden nebenwirkungen ist da
manchmal gar nicht notwendig in den
meisten industrieländern gilt krebs als
eine sehr häufige todesursache ein
italienisches forschungsteam
prognostiziert für das laufende jahr
2020 etwa 1,4 millionen krebs todesopfer
und das allein in der europäischen union
in deutschland könnten im jahr 2020 132
1400 männer und 100 10.000 frauen an
krebs sterben bei den männern ganz vorne
mit dabei sind der lungen und der
prostatakrebs bei den frauen sind es vor
allem brust und lungenkrebs
dementsprechend groß ist der druck
verlässliche früherkennungsmethoden zu
entwickeln in der vergangenheit wurden
bereits atem tests für darm- und
lungenkrebs entwickelt und auch ein
urintest für prostatakrebs war dabei von
zwei jahren hatten us fachleute dann in
der renommierten fachzeitschrift science
ein ergebnis präsentiert das für
aufsehen gesorgt hatte ein
forschungsteam der columbia university
hatte eine neue methode zur
früherkennung von krebs entwickelt mit
der es möglich sein sollte gleich acht
häufige krebsarten in einem frühen
erkrankungs stadium nachzuweisen
aufgespürt werden sollten damit tumore
in brust lunge bauchspeicheldrüse magen
leber eierstöcken darm und speiseröhre
das forschungsteam nutzte dafür die
sogenannte flüssig biopsie liquid
biopsie
denn wenn größere tumore entstehen
zerfallen oft krebszellen die dann ins
blut ausgeschwemmt werden dazu gehören
auch proteine die als tumormarker auch
heutzutage bereits genutzt werden um den
krankheitsverlauf zu kontrollieren aber
auch dna bruchstücke werden frei die
dann im blut zirkulieren der damals
entwickelte blut test mit dem namen
cancers sieg übersetzt also so viel wie
krebs suche kombiniert die suche nach
acht charakteristischen proteinen mit
der suche der dna von 16 krebsgene der
test lieferte vor allem zuverlässige
ergebnisse die weiter die
krebserkrankung fortgeschritten waren
besonders hoch war die trefferquote bei
eierstöcke lungenkrebs 98 prozent der
erkrankung wurden auf grundlage des
bluttests identifiziert anders dagegen
saß bei den brustkrebs patientinnen aus
hier wurden anhand der blutproben nur
ein drittel der erkrankten erkannt dazu
kommt in einer kontrollgruppe wurden
sieben von 800 personen als krebskranke
identifiziert fälschlicherweise denn sie
waren absolut gesund deswegen wurde
dieses studio kritisiert denn bei diesem
test sei es nicht ausgeschlossen dass
eigentlich gesunde menschen die
erschreckende krebsdiagnose bekommen
das führe zu unnötigen und kostspieligen
untersuchungen und zu einer großen
verunsicherung in der bevölkerung so die
kritik aber auch ärztinnen und ärzte
könnten durch falsche ergebnisse
verunsichert werden und sogar etablierte
vorsorge methoden wie mammographien oder
darmspiegelungen weniger nutzen
das würde im schlimmsten fall bedeuten
dass eine krebserkrankung unerkannt
bleibt und für den patienten oder die
patienten tödlich endet fest steht die
bislang entwickelten tests sind bis
heute nicht im klinischen alltag
angekommen und medizinerinnen und
mediziner müssen immer noch auf
aufwendige und unangenehme bildgebende
verfahren wie röntgen zum beispiel
setzen die ebenfalls nicht selten zu
falsch positiven ergebnissen führen
dennoch sind fachleute weltweit
optimistisch
dass solche bluttests im kampf gegen den
krebs entscheidend sein könnten und so
sorgt jetzt eine neue entwicklung in
diesem zusammenhang für aufregung in der
fachwelt wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen von der european
society for medical oncology esmo haben
einen neuen bluttest vorgestellt der
achtung 50 krebsarten im blut erkennen
und voneinander unterscheiden kann
nach angaben des forschungsteams kann
dieser test aber noch viel mehr
demnach zeigt er nämlich sogar an welche
organe und welches gewebe von tumoren
gefallen ist dieser test basiert auf der
analyse von epigenetischen veränderungen
die rede ist von kleinen chemischen
gruppen die von fachleuten als
methylgruppen bezeichnet werden und sich
an verschiedenen stellen des erbguts
befinden diese anlagerung sorgen dafür
dass die gene an dieser stelle nicht
abgelesen werden können
die gene werden quasi blockiert und
somit abgeschaltet werden diese metylan
lagerung aber entfernt sind die zuvor
blockierten gene wieder angeschaltet
diese sogenannten epigenetischen
veränderungen können dann dazu führen
dass tumor gene aktiviert werden der neu
entwickelte bluttest aus den usa also
analysiert die anlagerung solche
methylgruppen an mehr als einer million
position der dna dafür verantwortlich
ist ein selbstlernende algorithmus also
künstliche intelligenz ki
dieser ist nach angaben des us
forschungsteams in der lage anhand der
identifizierten muster nicht nur die
krebsart sondern sogar das befallene
gewebe zu bestimmen dafür musste die
software trainiert werden als
übungsmaterial wurden die blutproben von
rund 1.500 gesunden kontrollpersonen und
rund 1.500 krebs patientinnen und
patienten genutzt
die blutproben von knapp 1300 weiteren
teilnehmenden diente dann als grundlage
für die eigentliche studie dazu schreibt
das forschungsteam unseres wissens nach
ist dies das bisher umfangreichste
klinischen genomik programm bei dem ein
bluttest für die früherkennung
zahlreicher krebsarten entwickelt und
validiert wurde die untersuchung zeigt
dass die erkennungsrate des neu
entwickelten tests zwischen 18 und 93
prozent liegt auch hier hängt die
trefferquote zum einen vom stadium der
erkrankung und zum anderen von der
krebsart ab fortgeschrittene krebs im
stadion 4 wurde in bis zu 93 prozent der
fälle erkannt frühe tumorstadium 1
dagegen
bei 18 der versuchs teilnehmenden die
genauigkeit des blutes liegt bei allen
krebsarten und allen stadien im mittel
bei 43 9
das forschungsteam schreibt in der
aktuellen studie aber auch dass die
gesamt genauigkeit durchaus höher wird
wenn man sich auf die zwölf häufigsten
krebserkrankungen beschränkt wenn der
algorithmus also lediglich die zwölf
häufigsten krebserkrankungen wie
beispielsweise bauchspeicheldrüsenkrebs
blutkrebs magenkrebs darmkrebs
lungenkrebs und leberkrebs erkennen soll
liegt gesamt genauigkeit bei 67,3
prozent über alle stadien gemittelt doch
der algorithmus kann noch mehr in 96
prozent der positiv getesteten proben
gelang es ihm auch die betroffenen
gewebe und organe zu identifizieren dazu
der chefredakteur des fachmagazins
annals of oncology in dem die studie
jetzt veröffentlicht wurde
dies ist eine wichtige studie und ein
erster schritt zur entwicklung von
leicht einzusetzen screening werkzeugen
können die früherkennung von mehr als 50
prozent der krebsfälle könnte jedes jahr
millionen menschen neben weltweit rappen
doch besiegt ist es damit noch lange
nicht denn vor allem in sehr frühen
krebsstadium muss die genauigkeit noch
gesteigert werden dazu sind dringend
noch weiterführende studien nötig klar
ist jedenfalls dass es noch dauern wird
bis ein solcher bluttests auf den markt
kommt dennoch macht auch diese studie
aus den usa deutlich dass künstliche
intelligenz schon jetzt eine bedeutende
rolle in der krebsforschung spielt
fachleute sind sich sicher dass der
einsatz von ki zukünftig deutlich
zunehmen wird denn die daten die zur
verfügung stehen werden immer
umfangreicher und die methoden immer
komplexer kann bei der auswertung und
deutung von röntgenbildern gen sequenzen
gewebeproben und tumor marker im blut
eine riesige erleichterung sein
die wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen erhoffen sich
dadurch nicht nur eine höhere präzision
sondern auch eine enorme zeitersparnis
den klinischen alltag hat die künstliche
intelligenz noch nicht ganz durchdrungen
doch pilotstudien sind vielversprechend
so beispielsweise am deutschen
krebsforschungszentrum in heidelberg wo
fachleute ein künstliches neuronales
netzwerk entwickelt haben mit dessen
hilfe sollen kernspinaufnahmen der
prostata analysiert werden die
ergebnisse sind jetzt schon
vielversprechend denn die künstliche
intelligenz war in der lage verdächtige
bereiche in der prostata
sicher zu identifizieren wie erfahrene
radiologin und radiologen das neuronale
netzwerk wurde mit hilfe von mrt
aufnahmen von 250 patienten trainiert
das fertige modell wurde an 62
teilnehmern getestet die erkennungsrate
von klinisch relevanten prostata krebs
war hoch die künstliche intelligenz
erkannte die erkrankung bei 92 prozent
werden die radiologen und radiologen 88
prozent der patienten erkannten die an
einem klinisch relevanten thum erkrankt
waren dazu der heidelberger forscher
david bohnekamp der an der studie
beteiligt war
die ergebnisse zeigen uns dass die
künstliche intelligenz für die klinische
diagnostik großes potenzial bereit hält
jetzt arbeiten die fachleute daran
ähnliche methoden zu entwickeln und
diese dann auch startklar für den
klinischen alltag zu machen damit
könnten therapien dann viel früher
beginnen und so dann auch viel
erfolgreicher sein und auch an den
therapien wird geforscht und verbunden
mit der besseren diagnostik könnte krebs
dann nochmal deutlich besser behandelt
werden ein hoffnungsschimmer im kampf
gegen den krebs liegt auf der
sogenannten personalisierten therapie
diese therapie kommt zum einsatz wenn
eine frühzeitige diagnose verpasst wurde
in einem ersten schritt wird hierbei die
genetische veränderung analysiert die
den krebs auslöst mit medikamenten die
bereits verfügbar sind erfolgt dann ein
direkter angriff auf den tumor krebs
patientinnen und patienten sollen diese
idee zufolge also bald nicht mehr alle
nach demselben schema behandelt werden
sondern nach der spezifischen
empfindlichkeit des jeweiligen tumor
sprich und das wäre für die gesamte
medizin ein riesiger schritt es werden
nicht mehr alle patientinnen und
patienten über einen kamm geschert
sondern für jeden wird genau das
präparat gefunden das am besten wirkt
und es gibt ja tausende wirksubstanzen
in den unterschiedlichsten dosierungen
verabreichungsform und kombinationen an
der künstlichen intelligenz stehen sie
alle zur verfügung und dann stellt sich
dann zum beispiel bei krone heraus dass
ein mittel gegen krätze gegen das virus
wirken könnte und genauso könnten
wirkstoffe zugeschnitten auf den
jeweiligen menschen und den jeweiligen
tumor gefunden werden und in zukunft
vielleicht sogar individuell gebaut
werden quasi zum beispiel ein persönlich
für diesen patienten gebautes und
gefaltetes protein dafür muss dieser im
vorfeld genauestens analysiert werden
das ganze
jetzt erst möglich weil forschungsteams
in den vergangenen jahren großartige
arbeit geleistet haben so konnte man
erkennen dass es sich bei tumoren nicht
um einheitliche erkrankungen handelt so
gibt es beispielsweise nicht einen
lungenkrebs sondern verschiedene
untergruppen die charakterisiert sind
durch eine bestimmte mutation diese
treiber mutation macht den tumor aber
auch angreifbar und sein wachstum kann
durch wirksame zielgerichtete
medikamente gestoppt werden heißt also
ist erst einmal die genetische
veränderung bekannt kann der krebs
gezielt behandelt werden und zwar mit
medikamenten die bereits verfügbar sind
und diese wirkstoffe blockieren dann an
ort und stelle und zwar genau da wo der
krebs ausgelöst wird es erfolgt also ein
direkter angriff auf den tumor mit
medikamenten die quasi maßgeschneidert
für die jeweilige mutation der
tumorzellen sind potenziell tödliche
krebs erkranken könnten mit hilfe der
personalisierten therapie in chronischer
erkrankungen umgewandelt werden und die
lebensdauer der krebs patientinnen und
patienten könnte damit steigen durch die
personalisierte therapie könnte das
überleben der betroffenen um jahre
verlängert werden so die hoffnung der
fachleute statt in 20 prozent der fälle
wie bei der chemotherapie lässt diese
therapieform den tumor in 70 prozent der
fälle schrumpfen
die dafür notwendigen mit der rente gibt
es als tablette und diese ist deutlich
verträglicher als eine chemotherapie
doch nicht nur in sachen lungenkrebs
könnte die personalisierte therapie
erfolge bringen auch für andere
krebsarten wie etwa brust- oder
darmkrebs könnte sie relevant werden
denn auch hier werden die sogenannten
treiber mutationen nach und nach
aufgespürt in deutschland gibt es
mittlerweile 17 zentren die eine solche
genetische diagnostik durchführen auf
die dann eine personalisierte therapie
folgen kann
doch es gibt auch ein aber denn auch
wenn die personalisierte therapie große
hoffnung weckt fest steht dass wir damit
noch längst nicht in der lage sind den
krebs zu heilen aber damit auch immer
mehr auf künstliche intelligenz gesetzt
ich kann nur immer wieder den
meilenstein von deep meint der
google-tochter für künstliche
intelligenz in den alpha fund ein
programm dass proteine falten kann macht
das zehnmal besser als alles vorher da
gewesen eine herkulesaufgabe und jetzt
soll alpha holt bei der entwicklung
eines medikaments gegen kurve 19 helfen
deshalb schon sechs proteine gefaltet
die wirken könnten wenn die entwicklung
hier so schnell
weiter geht und die ki so schnelle
fortschritte machen wie zum beispiel
astronomie wo sie ständig neues
exoplaneten supernovae in alten daten
auf spürt dann haben wir auf jeden fall
eine vielversprechende zukunft vor uns
in der der krebs vielleicht wie die
pocken besiegt wird ist künstliche
intelligenz gut oder böse anklicken
anschauen und einen meiner lieblings
kanäle abonnieren doktor watson mit die
besten wissenschafts videos hier auf
youtube bis dann bleibt dran